hace un par de vídeos empezamos con una
gran pregunta nos preguntábamos cuál era
la base del espacio columna de esta
matriz am y bueno hicimos un método para
encontrar el espacio columna de la
matriz a para esto lo que buscamos fue
la forma escalonada de la matriz a que
es justo esta matriz r y nos fijamos en
sus columnas pivote fíjate que aquí
tenemos una columna pivote
aquí tenemos otra columna pivote porque
tenemos un 1 y todos los demás son ceros
y aquí tenemos otra columna pivote
porque también tenemos un 1 y los demás
son ceros entonces déjenme ponerlas en
un cuadrado y ahora si la pregunta
original de hace un par de vídeos era
saber cuál era una base del espacio
columna de la matriz
y entonces nuestros candidatos para
hacer esa base eran los vectores columna
que estaban asociados a nuestros
lectores pivote de la forma escalonada
de la matriz am es decir a 1 2 a 4 eran
nuestra base de nuestro espacio columna
de a a 1 2 a 4 formaban una base del
espacio columna de amd y bueno nosotros
lo que hicimos fue el procedimiento para
llegar
atrapar estos tres vectores ahora bien
lo que no vimos ese vídeo es que
realmente fueran una base del espacio
columna de amd y bueno para hacer una
base de espacio columna de amp se tiene
que cumplir dos cosas la primera es que
fueran linealmente independientes que
estos tres vectores frank linealmente
independientes que era justo lo que
vimos en el vídeo pasado es decir en el
vídeo que antecede a este de la serie
que estamos viendo en el vídeo pasado
vimos que estos tres factores serán
linealmente independientes porque los
vectores pivote columna asociados a
ellos es decir r1 r2 y r4 r 2 74 son
linealmente independientes y lo puedes
verificar muy sencillo porque aquí
tenemos un 1 y en todas las demás
entradas desde micro filas vamos a tener
un 0 por lo tanto si tomamos una
combinación lineal de los otros vectores
pivote no va a haber ninguna forma de
llegar a que estos tuvieran aquí un 1
porque todos los demás van a tener en
sus respectivas filas el valor de 0 que
por cierto esto funciona para todos los
vectores pivote si nosotros tomamos una
matriz de 40 por 40 de todas maneras va
a funcionar porque
la construcción de la forma escalonada
de la matriz ar es exactamente esta
poner un 1 en nueve las entradas y en
todas las demás entradas un cero muy
bien y por lo tanto vimos el vídeo
pasado que esto sea en elemento
independientes y llegamos a que estos
otros tres también eran linealmente
independientes entonces lo primero que
estábamos en la independencia lineal lo
cual ya lo tenemos ahora lo que quiero
ver en este vídeo es que si ya tenemos
la independencia lineal entonces a 1 a 2
a 4
el espacio vectorial generado por estos
es exactamente igual que el espacio
columna de a es decir que podemos
prescindir de a tres ideas 5 para
encontrar el espacio columna de a o de
otra manera que hay una combinación
lineal de los vectores a1 a2 día 4 tal
que nos dé el vector a 3 y que nos dé el
vector a 5 esto es justo lo que quiero
ver en este vídeo y si ya tenemos
independencia lineal y además sabemos
que generamos el espacio columna de a
por lo tanto pues estos tres vectores en
una base del espacio columna de a
entonces que es lo que quiero que si el
espacio vectorial generado por estos
cinco vectores déjame ponerlo aquí el
espacio vectorial generado
a 1 a 2 a 3 a 4 a 5 esto sabemos que ese
espacio columna de a y yo lo que quiero
ver es si puedo encontrar una forma de
escribir al vector a 3 y al vector a 5
como una combinación lineal de estos
tres vectores a 1 a 12 a 4 y si logro
prescindir de estos dos vectores
entonces me voy a dar cuenta que el
espacio vectorial generado por estos
tres vectores es exactamente igual que
el espacio columna de an que es justo a
lo que yo quiero llegar que generen todo
el espacio columna de a y bueno para
esto entonces recuerda que vamos a
intentar buscar una combinación lineal
de tres ideas 5 en términos de mis otros
tres vectores entonces vamos a empezar
primero con la forma escalonada de la
matriz anp vamos a recordarla y para
esto espera mejor de hecho vamos a
recordar primero espacios nudos si aquí
tengo a r2 r3 r4 y r7 entonces yo sé que
las soluciones de la ecuación a x igual
a 0
déjeme ponerlo aquí a x
igual a cero esto es más más déjeme
poner al vector x común el vector x1 y
x2 x 3 x 4 y x 5 si yo multiplico a la
matriz a por este vector x igual a 0 y
encuentro todos los posibles valores que
puede tomar este vector estoy hablando
del espacio nulo de la matriz am sin
embargo sabemos que este espacio en uno
de la matriz a es exactamente igual que
el espacio no de la forma escalonada de
la matriz am es decir esto es lo mismo
que tomar a r por el vector x 1 x 2 x 3
x 4 y x 5 y esto igual a 0
si encontramos todos los vectores que
cumplan esta ecuación entonces van a
cumplir también la ecuación a x igual a
0 y bueno también habíamos visto hace
tiempo que nosotros podíamos ver la
multiplicación de una matriz por un
vector de la siguiente manera a x igual
a 0 es exactamente lo mismo que poner x
1 por el vector columna a 1 es decir x 1
por a 1 + x 2 por el vector columna 2
más x 3 por el vector columna 3
x4 puede vector columna 4 + x 5 por el
vector columna 5 y esto igual a 0 es lo
que yo quiero que esto sea igual al
vector 0
y bueno si esto se cumple entonces
recuerda que tienen que ser los mismos x
1 x 2 x 3 x 4 x 5 para la ecuación rx
igual a cero por lo tanto también puedo
escribir que esto es exactamente igual
que si se cumple esto entonces pues yo
también tomarme a la matriz r que
multiplica el vector x pero escrito
también con sus vectores columna es
decir x1 por el vector columna r 1 + x2
por el vector columna r 2 ojo estamos
hablando de la forma escalonada de la
matriz am más x 3 x r 3 más x 4 por
entre 4 más x 5 por r 5 esto igual a 0 y
bueno como ya hemos visto en múltiples
vídeos si nosotros vemos a los que son
nuestros vectores columna pivote de la
matriz r es decir r1 r2 y r4 entonces
habíamos nombrado a las variables
asociadas a estos vectores r 1
y cuatro variables pivote es decir que
en este caso x1 y x2 y x 4 son nuestras
variable pívot en esto ya lo habíamos
visto en algunos vídeos y bueno también
habíamos dicho que aquellas variables
que no estuvieran asociadas a nuestros
lectores con una pivote así vamos a
llamar variables libres por lo tanto
aquí x 3 y x 5 van a ser mis variables
libres así que vamos a ponerles nombre
libres este x 5 es bastante libre y
bueno de igual manera si nosotros nos
fijamos en la forma a x igual a 0
entonces van a tomar los mismos nombres
las variables x 1 x 2 x 3 x 4 y x 5 por
lo tanto como ambas son soluciones de la
misma ecuación por lo tanto voy a decir
que x 3 en esta ecuación a x igual a 0 y
x 5 en esta ecuación a x igual a 0
también son variables libres y bueno
hace tiempo habíamos visto que unas
propiedades importantes que tenían las
variables libres es que podían tomar
cualquier valor en los números reales x3
x5 pueden tomar cualquier valor en los
números reales es decir estas dos
variables pueden ser lo que tú quieras
y además de todo esto habíamos visto que
entonces nuestras variables pivotes las
podríamos escribir como una combinación
lineal de estas dos y justo esta idea es
la que nos va a resolver este problema
es decir que x1 lo podríamos ver no se
común a veces x 3 más veces x 5 y x2
también la podemos ver como no se cebe
es x 3 + d veces x 5 ya x 4 también la
podemos ver como abs de veces x 3 +
efe pss x 5 ahora bien date cuenta que
ya llegamos un sistema de ecuaciones
tenemos a x1 como una función de x3 x5 a
x2 como también una función de x3 x5 y x
4 igual por lo tanto usando esta
información quiero que te des cuenta que
si nosotros nos fijamos en la matriz
original es decir en am vamos a poder
despejar de aquí tanto el vector a 3
como el vector a 5 y así vamos a poder
encontrar una combinación lineal que nos
de estos dos vectores en términos de los
otros tres vectores de a uno de a dos y
de cuatro y para esto vamos a empezar
con
imagínate que aquí tengo a tres y de
aquí la voy a despegar y para despejar
aquí el valor de a tres lo que tengo que
hacer es pasarla del otro lado con su
respectivo x 3 con signo contrario
entonces que me quedaría para esto voy a
reescribir esta ecuación pasando este
término del otro lado de la ecuación y
que me va a quedar
bueno pues va a pasar con signo
contrario es decir va a pasar con signo
negativo y me quedaría menos x 3 a 3
esto es igual a quien entonces
escribirlo aquí abajo
- x 3 que va a multiplicar al vector a 3
- x 3 que multiplica el vector a 3 esto
es igual a todos los demás nosotros no
cambiaron de lugar por lo tanto me
quedarían x 1 por el vector a 1 + x 2
por el vector a 2 + aquí no tenemos x 3
x 3 es justo lo que estamos despejando
entonces me quedaría más x 4 x a 4 + x 5
x a 5 muy bien ahora como x3 x5 son
variables que son libres pueden tomar el
valor que nosotros queramos por lo tanto
vamos a darles un valor que nos sirva
para que podamos encontrar esta
combinación lineal
x 3 y x5 pueden valer lo que sean
entonces voy a suponer que x 3 vale
menos uno y x 5 vale
0 si yo me tomo a x 3 igual a menos 1 y
x5 igual a cero que voy a encontrar
bueno déjame escribiendo aquí x 3 vale
menos 1 entonces esto se va me quedaría
un 1 positivo menos por menos me da más
entonces me quedaría solamente a 3 y del
otro lado si pongo a x 5 igual a cero
déjame escribirlo aquí voy a hacer a x 5
igual a cero entonces esto de aquí se va
se cancela entonces solamente me
quedaría que a 3 es igual a x 1 x a uno
más
x 2 x a dos más x 4 x a 4 y aquí está la
combinación línea que yo les decía ya
puede escribir en el vector columna a 3
como una combinación lineal de los otros
tres vectores es decir estoy encontrando
una combinación lineal para este vector
columna el cual no estaba asociado a
ningún vector pivote en la forma
escalonada de la matriz am como una
combinación lineal de los otros es que
es justo lo que yo quería y cómo puedo
saber que siempre pasa eso a bueno
porque es 1 x 2 y x 4
los puedo
encontrar explícitamente utilizando a x
3 igual a menos 1 y x 5 igual a 0
podemos sustituir el valor de x 3 igual
a menos 1 y de x 5 igual a cero en todo
este sistema ecuaciones que tengo aquí y
por lo tanto x 1 nos quedaría menos a
porque b x x 5 se desaparece porque x 50
x 2 no quedaría menos y x 4 muy parecido
entonces date cuenta que ya puedo tener
un valor explícito para x1 y x2 y x 4
porque están en función de x3 x5 y puedo
hacer lo mismo para el vector columna a
5 ya lo hice para 3 puede hacer lo mismo
para 5 que son mis dos vectores que no
están asociados a mis vectores pivote de
mi forma escalonada de la matriz am si
nosotros nos fijamos en esta ecuación
que tengo justo aquí si yo quisiera
hacer lo mismo para 5 pues entonces
pasaría de esto del otro lado pasaría
esto con signo contrario y después
podría decir que x 5 vale menos uno y x
3 vale 0 y entonces obtendría al vector
a 5 como una combinación de los vectores
a uno a dos ya cuatro de la misma manera
y espero que no te hayas perdido y hasta
aquí países de acuerdo conmigo porque
acabo de enseñarte que si yo me tomo
a 3 y al vector a 50 m ponerlos con el
color magenta si me tomo a estos dos
vectores los cuales estaban asociados
con los vectores libres los vectores
columnas libres de la forma escalonada
de la matriz am
entonces yo puedo hacer que estos
vectores inspectores columnas libres se
puedan escribir como una combinación
lineal de mis vectores pivote porque
pues si aplicamos el mismo procedimiento
lo que hice fue tomar ver a una de estas
vectores columnas libres y despejar la
del otro lado de la ecuación para que
entonces a la variable libre asociada
que tenga lado la hagamos igual a menos
1 y todas las demás variables libres las
hagamos igual a 0 y entonces con esto
vamos a encontrar que cada uno de estos
vectores columnas libres los voy a poder
escribir como una combinación lineal de
mis vectores columna asociados a los
vectores con una pivote de la forma
escalonada de la matriz y persona que
utilice en mi notación libre sin embargo
creo que me has entendido bastante bien
todo esto lo que estoy haciendo es que
acabo de encontrar que puedo escribir al
vector a 3 y el vector a 5 como una
combinación lineal de a1 a2 ya 4 y por
lo tanto el espacio vectorial generado
por
vectores a 1 a 2 a 4 es exactamente
igual que el espacio vectorial generado
por los cinco vectores que es
exactamente igual que el espacio columna
de a y por lo tanto ya había probado que
a linealmente independientes acabo de
probar que generan el espacio columna de
a y por lo tanto el conjunto de estos
tres vectores a 1 a 2 ya 4 y déjame
ponerlos con color azul estos tres
vectores son mi base de mi espacio
columna de a y además ya queda
demostrado bueno espero que no hayas
encontrado esto bastante confuso y
complejo y además hayas entendido la
importancia de la forma escalonada de la
matriz ham para encontrar la base del
espacio columna de a